que no desperdicie dos tercios de su potencia en calor,
como ocurre hoy en EE. UU.
Podríamos utilizar un poco más de energía nuclear, quizás,
aunque tendría que ser un tipo totalmente distinto de energía nuclear,
porque la tecnología de hoy simplemente no es rentable
con energías renovables cuyos costos están disminuyendo muy rápido.
Necesitaríamos un nuevo tipo de avión,
porque no creo que sea especialmente práctico
pedir al mundo entero que renuncie a los viajes aéreos,
sobre todo porque gran parte del Sur global
es, por primera vez capaz de pagarlo.
Necesitamos aviones que no produzcan carbono.
Necesitamos un nuevo tipo de agricultura.
Porque posiblemente no podemos pedir a la gente que renuncie a la carne
y sea vegana. Supondría una nueva forma de criar carne de res
o quizás una forma antigua,
porque ya sabemos que las técnicas tradicionales de pastoreo
pueden convertir las granjas de ganado
de las que se conocen como fuentes de carbono, que producen CO2,
en sumideros de carbono, que las absorben.
Si Uds. prefieren un remedio tecnológico,
quizá podríamos cultivar algo de eso en el laboratorio.
Quizá también podríamos alimentar el ganado con algas,
porque eso reduce sus emisiones de metano hasta en un 95 o 99 %.
Probablemente tendríamos que hacer todo esto,
porque como en todos los aspectos de este enigma,
el problema simplemente es muy extenso y complicado
para resolverlo de manera milagrosa.
Y no importa cuántas soluciones implementemos,
probablemente no podremos descarbonizar a tiempo.
Esa es la matemática aterradora a la que nos enfrentamos.
No podremos vencer el cambio climático,
solo podremos vivir con él y limitarlo.
Y eso significa que probablemente necesitaríamos
una cierta cantidad de lo que se conoce como emisiones negativas,
que también eliminan el carbono de la atmósfera.
Miles de millones de nuevos árboles, quizá billones de nuevos árboles.
Y plantaciones enteras de máquinas que atrapan carbono.
Quizá una industria el doble o el cuádruple del tamaño
del negocio actual de petróleo y gas
para deshacer el daño provocado por esas empresas en las últimas décadas.
Necesitaríamos un nuevo tipo de infraestructura,
hecha sobre un tipo distinto de cemento,
porque hoy, si el cemento fuese un país,
sería el tercer mayor emisor del mundo.
Y China está vertiendo tanto cemento cada tres años
como EE. UU. vertió en todo el siglo XX.
Debemos construir rompeolas y diques
para proteger a esas personas que viven en la costa,
muchas de las cuales son muy pobres para poder construirlos hoy,
lo que significa poner un fin a una geopolítica estrechamente nacionalista
que define el sufrimiento de aquellos que viven en otras partes
del mundo como insignificante,
incluso cuando lo reconocemos.
Este mejor futuro no será sencillo.
Sin embargo los únicos obstáculos son los humanos.
Eso puede no ser un gran consuelo,
si Uds. saben lo que yo sé sobre la brutalidad humana e indiferencia,
pero les prometo, que es mejor que la alternativa.
La ciencia no evita que tomemos medidas
ni tampoco la tecnología.
Tenemos las herramientas que necesitamos hoy para comenzar.
Por supuesto, también las herramientas necesarias para acabar
con la pobreza mundial, epidemias
y también con el maltrato hacia las mujeres.
Por eso, más que nuevas herramientas, necesitamos una nueva política,
una forma de superar todos esos obstáculos humanos:
nuestra cultura, economía,
nuestro estado de las cosas parcial,
nuestro desinterés en tomarnos en serio todo lo que realmente nos asusta.
Nuestra miopía.
Nuestro sentido de interés propio.
Y el egoísmo de los ricos y poderosos del mundo
que tienen el menor incentivo para cambiar cualquier cosa.
Ahora, ellos también sufrirán,
pero no tanto como los que menos tienen,
que han hecho menos para producir calentamiento
y se han beneficiado menos
de los procesos que nos han llevado a este punto de crisis
pero estarán más agobiados en las décadas venideras.
Una nueva política
convertiría el problema de gestionar esa carga,
dónde cae y con qué dureza,
en la máxima prioridad de nuestra época.
No importa lo que hagamos, el cambio climático transformará la vida moderna.
Cierta suma de calentamiento ya está lista y es inevitable,
lo que supone probablemente cierta suma de sufrimiento adicional también.
E incluso si tomamos medidas drásticas
y evitamos algunas de estas situaciones peores, realmente terribles,
esto supondría vivir en un planeta totalmente distinto.
Con una nueva política, economía,
una nueva relación con la tecnología
y una nueva relación con la naturaleza.
Todo un mundo nuevo.
Pero relativamente habitable.
Relativamente próspero.
Y verde.
¿Por qué no elegir ese?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)